hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
february 7 2022
222
2022 2000 doug flutie
what's going on who else was 22 was that
mike bosse
i don't remember anyway um
how are you
how was your weekend man i got to do my
makeup gig last night
i'm uh recording this on sunday at the
fantasy springs casino
and i got to tell you man
that was the rowdiest old school [ __ ]
crowd not really rowdy i just kept
getting [ __ ] heckled and stuff it was
amazing
it just took me back like all it i don't
know
it's been a while since i [ __ ] pissed
people off like that it wasn't a lot it
was only like two or three people
somebody got [ __ ] tased
like i'm i my i gotta tell you something
my hat's off to you i exposed my bald
head to everybody out there you guys
were not [ __ ] around
you got after it i was doing some bit
about rittenhouse
and i must have been some [ __ ] guy i
don't know
the uh the local chapter for the nra
that guy was he was just like not funny
right so we get into when i keep doing
the like i'm gonna stop the joke now
it's like oh fun time for me so i keep
going i go even harder and he's like
not funny
right
so then
he's so [ __ ] mad
like two jokes later it's a completely
different topic and he just goes
still not funny
they ended up throwing the guy out
um you know i had no idea i had no idea
that like it was it was [ __ ]
unbelievable he was acting
like for what i hear college gigs are
like now i you know i haven't done one
of those in a minute
um
but it was like jesus christ did you
just take a woman studies class like
what is your [ __ ] problem
i just i like for the life of me
for the life of me
um what the internet has done
to people i think the internet and this
this this [ __ ] never-ending pandemic
[ __ ] here which i don't even know
where we're at right now we're supposed
to wear masks now i don't even know
anymore
um
like i was at the playground today with
my kids and i'm just like what are we
doing here
is is it we we're outside
is the omicron like a [ __ ] cold like
what the [ __ ] is going on and this is
you know this is all my fault because
i have muted
all of that chatter
on my social media and i highly
highly recommend it i went on twitter
and you're able to just pick the top you
click on the topic uh mute this topic
and i muted it and it was [ __ ]
amazing
you know what i mean
it was like
your parents are not yelling at each
other anymore
they like left the house so they're like
in a good mood or something that's what
it becomes and anybody who was talking
about that [ __ ] and pontificating i just
muted
all of it
and it just all went away
and social media became fun again
it was just clips of people being silly
trying to be funny sports clips just
[ __ ] like that jokes
having a great [ __ ] time so anyway
this [ __ ] guy
got his ass thrown out
um
i don't know like i was probably like
three bits in i don't know about 10
minutes into the show
i can kick the guy out
somewhere in there
somebody did something
that they ended up getting tased like i
i didn't
and i got to tell you whoever got tased
took it like a [ __ ] man or a woman
because i didn't hear it
you would think
if somebody got tased even if it was in
the back row you hear
you'd hear that you know
like i watch all those people like who
decide to let themselves get tased
there's two people they either scream
like i would scream or they do that that
internal they just go like
and they just [ __ ] face plant
[Laughter]
like somebody that's squatted with too
much weight what is the [ __ ] what's
going on with that by the way
there's something about
doing back exercises or
squatting it always seems to be like
that that forward bend and then you like
you just
you bent at the waist and you pick up
the barbell with that reverse grip like
one on the front one in the back and
then you like stand up
and then you just you you lift the
weight and then for some reason
everybody young has to do the 300 yell
if they accomplish anything
you know letting everybody know what a
beast you are so they just lift it up
they just go like
and then they drop it and then they walk
two steps and they just face plant into
all the other dumbbells
i'll tell you all the places to face
plant you don't want to be near a
[ __ ]
workout rack that in a bathroom
porcelain tile that is just [ __ ]
split your head open
territory you know what i mean
if i was still a young man and i was
[ __ ] able to lift that kind of
[ __ ] weight i do it in my living room
and i have a couch right in front of me
so then i just go
and i would just wake up face down in
pillows
[Applause]
instead of waking up with a [ __ ]
split skull and half like a number 15
you know whatever [ __ ] pound weight
you ran into
so anyway whoever that was shout out to
you
and then some poor woman i guess maybe
you know there was a casino comp
and she at one point just yelled out
stop making fun of women
and i was just like
no
i'm doing my jokes
and then i was kind of like
like who did you think you were coming
to see like this has kind of been
a track record thing for me and i'm also
trying to do an uplifting bit about
feminism if you let me get to the end of
it
i'm trying to say that you know you guys
have the numbers
and you're smarter than us you're just
not letting me get to the end of it
but i don't know
looking back i probably should have said
like yeah you're right i have been going
a little hard
why do you think i'm doing that and i
could have got it could have had a much
better conversation with her and then
she ended up leaving but the rest of the
people
were all amazing and fantasy springs was
awesome
i love going out to places like that i
love doing those [ __ ] casino gigs
that aren't at the casino you know what
i mean
like on the you know i like doing vegas
strip who what comedian doesn't but i
like those other ones are fun as [ __ ]
they're just always fun
crowds a few people got too rowdy but i
mean jesus christ
somebody out there actually has a story
i went to a comedy show and got tased
like how does that happen how does it
happen
um
whatever but what all it did was just
make me
understand
how bad people want to get out of the
house
and everybody's just fed up with this
[ __ ] and just want it to be over so
i don't know i muted everything but i
feel like it's sort of burning out i
don't know
i don't know that's me weighing in
there's my medical opinion i feel like
it's kind of burning itself out
hopefully
hopefully that's what that's what is uh
that is what happened
so anyway oh freckles
has an acting gig coming up
and um
i'm putting together this uh this movie
that i wrote with a buddy of mine
you know
who knows i you know these things they
can fall apart at any second so who
knows i'll let you know guys know what
happened but i
have never realized
how easy i had it just being an actor
just showing up like the amount of work
and how hard everybody has to [ __ ]
work i did a pass of the script
where they're going like okay and like
they every single prop
you just take it for granted they'll
just be like okay in this scene
you know what was it a grill it says he
has a grill in the backyard this
character what do you think does he have
a charcoal grill
does he have a gas grill is it one of
those gas grills that goes you know gets
the gas from the house
or does he have one of those little
[ __ ] things you go down to home depot
for i always forget what you call those
things
um
you know
what kind is it silver is it one of
those black ones i mean literally the
whole
[ __ ] script what kind of couches do
you think this this character has in
this house it is just an astounding
amount of work so um
and thank god i have a bunch i have a
beast of a lineup of department heads
helping me out with this stuff but i'm
just sitting there going like
i just i i had no idea i mean i knew it
was a lot of work but i had no [ __ ]
idea but i'm also having a good time
doing it so
having said that
you know i haven't had a chance to fly a
helicopter in a while so uh i went up
today with my instructor
and uh
took it out flew it around the yard
haven't had a [ __ ] blast
just had a blast it was a perfect day
there was nobody up there
and
um we flew out of the valley and then we
just went around
went around like i don't know
out to glendale and then came back
around hollywood
right by the [ __ ] capitol records
building
and then all the way out to the beach
up
through malibu
up over the [ __ ] mountains right by
the ronald reagan library
berry library you tell me times i've
gone to a library i can't even say the
[ __ ] word
uh
that's yeah that would take me out of a
spelling bee
uh library uh
l-i-e-b-e-r-r-y
library man what do they do
don't they like ring a bell it's a weird
sound in the spelling bee when you're
out
it sounds like you got it right
like ding oh yay
that would be the best
just show up as a [ __ ] you spell it
wrong and then you hear like the [ __ ]
thing
and you act like you think you actually
legitimately think you get it right you
do the jim florentine yay
and you go
back over to sit down and then somebody
has to come over and be like no no buddy
it's over it's over for you
you're gonna be a ditch digger
what do i do now um you got a buddy you
used yours that cleans up yards starting
his own [ __ ] landscaping business
that was a big gig when i was a kid
landscaping landscaping
riding in the back of the truck and just
going into old people's yards and
[ __ ] cleaning them up
just absolute backbreaking work even in
your teens and your 20s
that [ __ ] dead [ __ ] job jesus
christ
the few times i did that that really
made me think i should have applied
myself in school
i now know what these people were
talking about jesus christ
you know i'm not talking about landscape
design horticulture that type of [ __ ]
i'm just talking
landscaping
bare bones come over here mow the lawn
rake it up rake up the leaves
edge it do all of the [ __ ]
spreading the peat moss
shovel it out into a [ __ ] wheelbarrow
i mean i don't know how they do it
nowadays they probably have drones doing
it but like when i was a kid
you showed up and you cut off jean
shorts
you know
for some reason everybody had a knife
you know one of those [ __ ]
knives on their [ __ ] belts and then
you just walked around
with your cut off jeans
right and your socks
and your work boots
and by like nine in the morning all the
hair on your legs was just covered like
it was like this
dirt mist
on your [ __ ] legs
i just remember eating sandwiches on the
back of the truck and your nails would
just be like just black
you know and then being a redhead like i
just couldn't do it it's the same reason
why i don't golf i just you know i could
landscape at night you know
if they had nighttime golf courses
which i'm sure they have somewhere maybe
in alaska during that time of year you
know when it's always [ __ ] dark
for most of the year
i could handle that but yeah i just what
i just was not built for any of that
[ __ ]
so anyway um
yeah but but leading up to fantasy
springs i want to make sure my hack was
up to speed i tried out all this new
[ __ ]
at the comedy store and just had i just
had the best [ __ ] time
trying out all the new [ __ ] and uh oh
god i got this new one i'm so excited
about
and it just did not go well at fantasy
springs it went well it didn't go as
well as i wanted it to
it's just like [ __ ] all right
i gotta go try it again
figure out what i said i should tape my
sets but i never do
um
so anyway
um
this is always like a tough weekend as a
sports fan
you know when the pro bowl's on
it just lets you there's all that
excitement
from the afc nfc championship game holy
[ __ ] the cincinnati bengals who saw them
coming
and the rams are they going to redeem
that loss to the new england patriots
is their boy wonder coach
going to get that ring
and silence his critics right
and just week out it's patrick mahomes
and all these guys they're all gonna
they're gonna get back and all of this
[ __ ] and oh my god that bill's chiefs
game [ __ ] unbelievable especially if
you're not into defense right [ __ ]
crazy all amped up and then there's just
that
they just [ __ ] back off
at least they put the police to put the
pro bowl after the two-week break
between the championship games the
conference championship in the super
bowl now they put the pro bowl in the
middle
and i just i refuse to watch the [ __ ]
pro bowl like watching contact sports
all-star games pro bowls it's just like
they're going to go half speed
like i watched 10 minutes the nhl
all-star game i think when i was
watching it i thought these were like
old-timers or college players they were
skating so [ __ ] slow it was three on
three which is so [ __ ] exciting
when they're playing but they were just
like i saw one guy go out and do a shift
it's like that guy's not even gonna have
to take a [ __ ] shower at the end of
this game he just was just gliding
around
he looked like he was at a [ __ ]
public skating rink but i get it
i get it
they're risking millions of dollars and
all of this type of [ __ ] to go out and
play a game that doesn't matter i could
i kind of gathered that there was
something
there was some sort of carrot they were
dangling
something about a million dollars
i don't know what
i don't know what it was they somebody
mark messier and um
uh who else was on it
um chris chellios
you know to the superstars from when i
was a kid to my uh you know i like
chellios after he left the uh the
canadians just as a bruins fan i
couldn't admit how much i i like that
guy he's just a great [ __ ] player i
think he played chicago and detroit
played forever
uh but those are the three teams i
remember him on but anyways they
mentioned something about a [ __ ]
million dollars or something i don't
know what it was but i was
i couldn't watch the [ __ ] game
um
i feel like the the mlb all-star game is
a good one
because the pitchers go in
you know
they're only pitching for an inning so
they can go hard and they don't want to
give up a [ __ ] home run and then all
the batters you know they'd want to go
up there and strike out i just feel like
you know
because it's like one-on-one pitcher
versus batter
they know everybody's watching so they
can't go there and like
not perform plus they're not going to
get tackled they're not gonna blow out a
[ __ ] acl
nba all-star game's another good one
you know you get to see all these
guys just doing [ __ ] you would never do
in a game there's no defense who gives a
[ __ ] it's fun but the nh all-star game
nhl all-star game and and the [ __ ]
pro bowl stink
sorry to say that because those are my
two favorite sports all right there i
said it
um
so anyway next week is the super bowl
and um
i think i'm gonna bet the uh
i think i'm gonna bet the [ __ ]
the bengals
you know
i don't know
that offensive line
can just somehow give joe burrow time
he's gonna i think he's gonna be fine i
think the i think the bengals have is
good good enough good enough defense
and if that wasn't the lamest
analogy of the game
then i don't think he watched football
whatever i'm an lsu fan that's why i'm
betting on the bengals because i like
joe burrow that's it
that's all there is all right i don't
know i don't know what to tell you uh
but it should be a great game
last i checked was only a three point
spread
i saw this thing on real sports when
they were sitting there talking about
how [ __ ] uh
you can actually gamble on the game at
the stadiums now
i mean they're literally turning it into
the track the [ __ ] pro bowls in vegas
you know my whole life growing up they
just stared
clear of all of that [ __ ] and they would
never
ever in any sport
dream
of uh
you know putting a game in vegas because
it was still run by the mob in the 70s
and they're like they're gonna get their
[ __ ] hooks in on a player and they're
gonna start throwing games and we're
gonna have a 1919 chicago white sox
scandal one of my missions in baseball
to stop calling them the black sox
it was the chicago white sox that did
that
they call them the black socks it sounds
like it's a team that no longer exists
they did that [ __ ]
and what's funny was they never got
called for like the curse
they were never considered cursed
you know we sold
babe ruth because we were you know
our owner was into the arts he wanted to
put on a musical
you know actually entertain the good
people in new york and he gave him babe
ruth to boot
it was a nice gesture i felt by the red
sox but we were considered cursed
[ __ ] white sox throw the world series
make all these little white kids around
america boy oh boy i love baseball
oh joe say it ain't so
[Laughter]
the big stupid paper route hats and
everything crying in the [ __ ] crowd
and they were never considered cursed
but the cubs were because somebody
wasn't allowed to bring their farm
animal
into a stadium
i never understood why the white sox
didn't get more [ __ ] for that
um and i think it was the brilliance
that they called it the black socks and
they just [ __ ] stepped away wasn't us
that was the black sox and now we're the
white sox again
and that was it they got away with the
whole thing and i'm here to rip the
cover off this scandal sorry
um
anyway oh billy freckles is finally
eating well
finally losing weight
all right my little [ __ ] belly my little
baby pooch is starting to finally
[ __ ] go down and uh i don't know
we'll see
we'll see you know i gotta get i gotta i
gotta [ __ ]
what did i do the other day i went to a
fitting on the movie i was like you
gotta be [ __ ] kidding me you know
i'll tell you what the the one of the
worst things for this country
that has happened
in in in i don't know how many years all
right
was when they started making jeans with
the elastic waist
the waistband
like who is that helping back in the day
when you started putting on weight those
[ __ ] jeans dug into you and they left
a [ __ ] red mark borderline welt
okay and you knew
that you had one of two choices
you either started eating a [ __ ]
salad or you had to start pushing those
things south now you know i know a lot
of the rappers and all of that
get credit for that style but you know
for wearing your pants down below your
dick and i'm here to tell you that there
was a lot of fatties that did that first
still confetti 32 inch jean you know
just pushing it down your [ __ ] body
so
i actually moved a notch down
on my belt it's a little tight
but i should be there by the end of the
week and then uh
then that's the last notch of my belt
and i i gotta i gotta i gotta stop this
[ __ ] guys
i don't know i always thought if i quit
drinking that you know the weight would
come off and it does initially but then
you're just so [ __ ] bored
you got to do something you know
you missed the [ __ ] rush
you know
stupidest thing i ever did was i went
out i ordered malt
uh
off the internet and i started making
myself chocolate malts like once a week
i would have one
you know combine and then that would
just get all this sugar in me and then i
would want salt and the next you know
the next day i meant like
eating a [ __ ] italian sandwich or
something
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie i
had a lot of fun getting this out of
shape but uh it is not fun walking the
[ __ ] road back i can tell you that
right now
um anyway
my son set off my car alarm today
the
kid is hilarious
he gets anything in his hand with
buttons he starts he gets the remote
control he just starts pushing all the
buttons and he's looking at the screen
you know one day i was backing my car
out
and as i was backing out i just heard
boom right
and the [ __ ] gate closed on my car
i'm like what enough how the [ __ ] did i
hit the gate it was cl he and i'm
standing look up at him and he's still
pushing the button like with all of his
might he's just pushing
the [ __ ] remote
[ __ ]
[ __ ] up my door
um
so today he was playing with my car keys
and i just let him he was pushing the
buttons and the
[ __ ] you know locks were going on and
off i'm like all right buddy all right
buddy and then also the key set off the
alarm
[Music]
and i'd never done that with the with
the thing and i was pushing the buttons
and i couldn't get it to get off i
finally had to get in the car and go to
start it up and it shut it off
and i got out you know he was crying
because he didn't like the noise
and then after he stopped crying
he just looks at me and he starts going
he literally goes beep beep beep beep
it's like wow
he learned a new word good for you buddy
he's talking he's talking now it's
awesome
he can say everybody's names
my favorite word he says is apple
i'll be like buddy say apple and he just
goes apple
he really hits the first heart and then
the first hard and then he lets it taper
off it's the coolest thing ever say
apple buddy
[Laughter]
uh he's the best all right
let's uh
let's do some advertising here for this
week ladies and gentlemen uh true bill
um do you know why free tiles renew this
this this really scares the [ __ ] out of
me and i wonder how much i'm paying here
true bill do you know why free trials
renew without your consent
it's a business scam out to get you
uh yeah demon and i just don't pay
attention now don't let greedy
corporations pocket your money download
truebill to take control of your
subscriptions truebill is the new app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need want
or simply forgot about that's me simply
forgot about you're simply stupid
on average
people save up to 720 a year with true
bill
that's like 60 70 bucks a month if my
math is right because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel true build
makes it incredibly simple just link
your accounts and truebill will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in one tap
and your true bill concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to
truebill has over 200 million users and
has helped save them over 100 million
dollars like matthew b oh [ __ ] what does
matthew b have to say
um in a matter of seconds i saved six
hundred sixty dollars
for the year
on my direct tv bill saved 120 for the
year or my serious xm bill
saved 840 a year on car insurance don't
fall for insurance scams start canceling
today at truebill.com burr go right now
truebuild.com it could save you
thousands of dollars truebill.com
t-r-u-e-b-i-l-l
dot com
b-u-r-r
all right
what do we got next here
is that it no true bill oh stamps.com
stamps.com you know people time is money
that's what successful people say hey
time is money don't waste either with
repeated trips to the post office with
stamps.com you can skip the trip and
focus on how to take your small business
to the next level
stamps.com lets you print official us
postage right from your computer and
saves you money on the in the process so
you can spend less time at the post
office and more time making your
customers happy
uh you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over nine years now and if you haven't
tried it what the [ __ ] are you waiting
for stamps.com saves you time and money
and stress for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been
indispensable for over one million
businesses
stamps.com gives you access to all the
post office and ups shipping services
you need right from your computer and
get discounts uh you can't find anywhere
else like up to 40 off usps
rates and 76 off the us uh ups sorry
is this all part of the same copy it's a
lot of copy here uh whether you're an
office
sending invoices a side hustle etsy
shop or a full-blown warehouse shipping
out orders stamps.com will make your
life easier all you need is a computer
and a standard printer no special
computer no special supplies or
equipment you're up and running in
minutes printing uh official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send stop paying for shipping with
stamps stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com
sign up with the promo code bur for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and enter bur b-u-r-r oh my
goodness just when you thought it was
safe to go back in the water
it's roman
hey man it's almost valentine day in
love
it's in the air
uh whether it's the third date or the
30-year anniversary you don't want
erectile dysfunction getting in the way
of a perfect night
i think she'd forgive you after 30 years
um if you've been experiencing erectile
dysfunction
then uh visit getroman.com
today to speak with the u.s licensed
health care professional about erectile
dysfunction and if prescribed you get 15
off your first month of treatment a us
licensed health care professional will
work with you to find the best treatment
plan if prescription medication
is appropriate it ships to you free
two-day shipping to make sure two days
and two days your dick's gonna be
standing up like what i miss
what i miss
to make sure you get your package in
time for valentine's day your order
needs to be placed by friday uh by
february 9th so don't waste any time
start the online visit today with roman
you get free ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home the whole process
is straightforward you get it straight
forward convenient and discreet getting
started is simple just go to get roman
r-o-m-a-n dot com slash bur b-u-r-r and
complete an online visit that's
getroman.com all right
so
hang on
i know what's been going on with me
lately man if i [ __ ] sit down my nose
gets [ __ ] clogged up and i gotta
become a mouth breather here you should
go to an ear nose and throat doctor i
should stop smoking cigars which i i'm
[ __ ] i'm trying like hell to do it
but i just love it man i need it all
right russia's aggression
dear billy b cup
[Laughter]
dude i'll take a b cup
i would love to be a b cup
all right i think i'm a full c at this
point i'm a looker
um english is my third language so
apologies for my linguistic fuck-ups in
advance
stop showing off dude the fact that you
could write that sentence in another
your third language
aren't you [ __ ] fancy
i'm jealous i'm admitting it all right
it's hilarious to listen to americans
view of the russian ukraine
uh
air quote conflict you know what buddy
it's it's [ __ ] hilarious to listen to
you dumb [ __ ] talk about our [ __ ]
country you live on the other side of
the world you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on over here i am so sick of
people in other countries acting like
they're not a bunch of [ __ ]
mouth-breathing morons that are at the
mercy of whatever information that
they're getting
all right so [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
three languages that i'm impressed with
just just give me the information i get
it we're on the other we're on a [ __ ]
island over here man
the [ __ ] do you know about the nhl
nothing i'm not going to get a give you
[ __ ] about it
all right
are you comparing the national hot
hockey league to international policies
and possible war yes i
am
yes i am
you know why because that's how awesome
it is over here
all right
anyways he's giving a [ __ ] here in fact
it's an it's an it's a ongoing war since
2014.
oh i watched this documentary i thought
you guys all went on facebook and told
the russians to go home and they were so
embarrassed that they did
that didn't happen
uh russia was the one who invaded the
ukraine americans are forgetting that
there is more than just western
imperialism
no we're not forgetting that we're just
not up on the ukraine you guys haven't
had a hit in a while
okay
win a [ __ ] world cup or bomb somebody
and then we'll know more about you i'm
sorry
jesus christ you're like a punk band
you're like the punk band version of a
country over there you know that's how
it [ __ ] works
why don't you intelligently talk to me
about some countries that that i don't
can't even name in south america
listen buddy i have world news on mute
okay i i i i i can't listen to this [ __ ]
i can't watch human beings i i hate that
russia's doing this [ __ ] to you all
right i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't have
all the [ __ ] facts
i'm an ocean away from you
americans are forgetting that there is
jesus christ this you're going to make a
great wife someday you just stay on
topic just keep berating americans are
forgetting that there is more than just
okay western imperialism there are also
russian
and chinese look at the chinese getting
some [ __ ] there all right for once it's
not just us
i have lived next to russia all my life
due to the chicks as hot as they say
sorry i'm just going to ask dumb
american questions we are used to russia
russia bullying its neighbor all the
time russians divide and conquer
policies
uh
are forcing countries to join nato
finland for example
finland which by the way
uh defeated russia in world war ii
right
but they were in bed with old [ __ ]
h-town over there so they still had to
give up part of that country
they won that one fair and square
finland for example is usually pretty
neutral in its geopolitical stage that's
probably because they won a war and
still had the loss because of
the [ __ ] broad they got in bed with
in world war ii
but now the support to join is raising
also what seems to be lost to most
people is that nato had joined military
exercises with russia in the 90s
what do you mean they joined them i
thought it was just a bunch of suits
telling people what to do
i'll be honest with you what is that the
north american trade organization treaty
organization
yeah many times i've said nato like
anyone who's talking about that violates
the nato [ __ ] agreement
because i heard somebody say that
nato
meaning all right here we go north
american treaty organization
all right
oh this was to avoid any more world wars
well get mad at the [ __ ]
germans
for throwing two keggers last [ __ ]
century
they're the reason this [ __ ] thing
exists uh the north atlantic
north i said north america north
atlantic treaty organization was created
in 1949 by the united states canada and
several western european nations to
provide collective security all against
the soviet union oh i didn't know that
sorry i thought it was the germans
um nato was the first peacetime military
alliance the united states entered into
outside of the western hemisphere after
the destruction of the second world war
the nations of europe struggled to
rebuild their economies and ensure their
security the former required a massive
influx of aid to help the war-torn
landscapes re-establish industry and
produce food and the latter required
assurances against a resurgent germany
or incursions from the soviet union
the united states viewed an economically
strong rearmed and integrated europe as
vital to the prevention of communist
expansion across the continent so look
at that
we came over and we helped you rebuild
and protect you against russia and what
do you guys do how do you repay us you
just make a bunch of fat jokes
how quickly
you [ __ ] sons of [ __ ] forget all
right sorry i didn't know any of that
two seconds ago i think i had to
memorize that one time for a test so no
nato is not to blame in this case
well then why did i just read all of
that [ __ ]
wait
wait okay nato had joined military
exercises with russia oh wait a minute
they were they were they were all now i
get it they were organized to stop these
guys and now they're in bed with them
this is like a soap opera
since putin oh god what a hockey player
he is in power
uh has been refusing any corpora
cooperation so no nato is not to blame
in this case in fact it's the only
deterrent to russia land grabbing more
land
just out of curiosity how much bigger
does russia have to get
i mean they're like the [ __ ] they're
like a superstore except they're a
country
they're [ __ ] gigantic
is that because so much of it is snow
wait a minute does global warming
oh my god russia's gonna be amazing
all of that [ __ ] and then you can't send
people to siberia that's like gonna be
like sending them to the [ __ ] bahamas
wait are you gonna tell me that russia
is behind global warming at the end of
this all right i'm just going to keep
going here p.s soviets
were the one calling everyone
disagreeing with them fascists aka nazis
before the sjws
what are the sjws not jesus christ
internetslang.com
s j
w
single jerk women
what does that mean
oh social justice warriors
oh yeah enough
[ __ ]
as a liberal it's really those guys are
the most embarrassing of the liberals
they're the jerry springer guest of
liberals uh thanks for the content and
go [ __ ] yourself all right i know i gave
you a lot of [ __ ] i appreciate you and
your three [ __ ] languages and
for breaking that down i bet a lot of my
listeners understood a lot more than i
did
so russia has been [ __ ] with ukraine
since 2014.
they invaded the ukraine the americans
are forgetting okay
[Music]
russia's divide and conquer policies are
forcing countries to join nato why would
they want them to join nato
wait did russia
eventually join nato
the way drug companies put their own
people in the fda is that what happened
hold on a second
nato members
okay albania belgium bulgaria canada
croatia czech republic denmark
estonia france germany greece hungary
iceland italy latvia lithuania
luxembourg
montenegro
netherlands north macedonia oh those
southern macedonians they they don't
want to be part of anybody's party
norway poland portugal romania slovakia
slovenia
spain turkey united kingdom
and the united states wait a minute
so what who the [ __ ] did they grease
oh because they're dividing and
conquering people this is making
countries join nato
oh all right i'm sorry for everybody
who's been screaming that at me for the
last five minutes in your car
whatever it's got to make you feel
better this is all i'm just here to make
you guys feel better i just make you
laugh i want to make you feel smarter
just to begin your week that's all
that's all i'm trying to do here ukraine
slash russia
dear billy two-tone
i don't even know what that means
uh i like it
tommy two-tone um eight six seven five
three oh nine the russian you the russia
ukraine issue was misrepresented last
week in an email you read the us is
using nato to put pressure on russia
russia is flexing the way we do in the
middle east which is why people think
it's hypocritical for the u.s to act
like they care
um
well no one cares
no one cares no one cares people care
about themselves that's what i have
learned
in my travels there's and people that
really care about other people
are not really in have any sort of sense
of power and they actually understand
life more so than people who are in
power or maybe i'm oversimplifying being
in a powerful position there's just a
lot of [ __ ] up people out there and
they like power and they get it and then
they do [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right
um
i know the us doesn't care u.s didn't
give a [ __ ] about americans in in like
hurricanes they don't we
i get it
i get it uh both d and r they don't give
a [ __ ] about people of mental illness
they shut down all the [ __ ] nut
houses and just threw those people out
on the street they're living under
bridges it's [ __ ] crazy
i understand that um both d and our pub
uh parties democratic and republican
parties are pushing for this
mobilization of nato troops funny how
military action is the only thing both
parties can ever agree on and the fun
part ab that's how they make their money
uh and the fun part about this hot topic
is that if you speak against the use of
troops and mobilizations you're somehow
pushing russia proper russian propaganda
well what are they supposed to do
i think
you have psychos running both countries
and they know what either side's going
to do and they want to be the psycho
that's in charge
that's what i think is that what you
think bill no
it's just the first thing i thought of
and then i said it all right bank
robbery story all right let's get out of
this [ __ ] international jesus christ
um
all right bank robbery story uh when i
was in university
no jesus christ that's one of the most
pretent pretentious beginnings of a
[ __ ] sentence ever but i know this is
from a different country when i was in
university
i worked part-time as a teller
if you go to a community college you
have to start saying that
if you went to a community college
where'd you go to college uh when i was
in university i was on the hill of
bunker
um when i was in university i worked
part-time as a teller at a bank here in
toronto i was talking about bank
robberies
last week and how you can rob a bank
with just a note and has anybody called
anybody out
yeah you know
give me all the money i have a gun
all right and then you just write back
[ __ ] off unless you show me it
and they just have to walk out of the
bank
um
i work part time as a teller at a bank
here in toronto
one morning when the bank just that's a
great beginning to a movie
[ __ ] off until you show me and he pushes
it right
and then the guy on the other side pulls
out a gun
tries to shoot
shoots through the glass but the guy who
said show it to me ducks and then the
manager gets [ __ ] one right in the
head
and then what happens i don't know
there's a love interest um when i was in
university i worked part time as a
teller at a bank here in toronto one
morning when the bank just opened and
relatively uh
and relatively empty two men masked came
in screaming saying they had guns hands
in their hoodie pockets pretending like
they had guns the [ __ ] balls that
takes
to risk your freedom and then not what
if there's a guy in there that has a gun
anyway they walked over to the vault and
tried to open it when they realized the
vault was locked they ran out of the
bank
the dumb [ __ ] assumed it was like a
movie where the vault door would open
and there would be a pile of cash just
sitting there the best part of the story
is they ended up getting caught no way
about an hour later based on a witness
seeing them flee these [ __ ] got
charged and went to jail
without a loonie to show for it
um i guess that means any money
some loot
all the best and go leafs and raptors
toronto fan all right good luck to both
your teams there
wow i bet they don't tell that story in
prison what are you in prison for
robbing a bank how'd you do it
you know i uh
i'll tell you later
they never tell you how much i like your
shank
um
dad robbed a bank
wow
dear billy baby back ball sack burr
all right you went with the long one
there i want my baby back baby back baby
back baby back baby back baby bag ball
sack baby back i'll go baby back baby
back baby bag baby ballsack that's a
tough one to do long time listener first
time caller thanks for making my drive
to work suck less that's that's all i'm
here for
you're definitely not here to be
educated i've listened to you discuss
bank robberies recently
and that made me think of this story
my dad
my dad who's past now was a [ __ ]
badass when he was younger he and my mom
did a good job of hiding his
transgressions from me as a kid but when
he found out that he had alzheimer's and
was going to lose his mental capacity he
decided to sit me down and tell me a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] he did as a kid
before he forgot about it
was he worried that he was going to
babble about it
that's pretty cool that he acted like he
was just a straight lace guy
anyway he was a very intelligent guy he
worked for the family car
salvage yard
which had its start
uh through less than legal means i'm not
[ __ ] with you he could look at a car
a car key someone was holding in their
hand and he could cut a copy from a
memory later on
which he would use to steal the car and
strip it for parts
i mean there's another great character
for a movie he almost got caught when he
did this to his girlfriend at the time's
father
he stole his dad's car jesus chris his
girlfriend's dad's car wow
what took the cake though was his bank
robbery story when he was 18 he had a
buddy who worked at his town's bank
long story short they plotted a robbery
my dad was let into the vault by his
friend and he walked out with a duffel
bag containing 400 000 in cash in broad
daylight carried it down the street and
everything my dad hid the money
and they were going to split it once
things cooled down at the time he set
the state record for the largest bank
heist
yeah things are not going to cool down
[Laughter]
unfortunately the fbi got involved gee
who saw that coming
this was a large sum of money obviously
400k
then is worth 1.5 million today and his
parents got suspicious because he was
acting weird
that's what they thought they didn't
think is he gay is he
did he get his girlfriend pregnant like
the usual [ __ ] is he doing drugs they're
like
he's acting strange
i wonder if he robbed a bank
dude you got a badass family tree
if that's what they think
allegedly his parents got him to admit
to them what he did
and they called the fbi the fbi came out
and basically scared him into ratting on
his friends like a little [ __ ] he did
it as a result neither of them got any
jail time
sounds like a white story here they just
had to return the money he never gave up
where he had hidden the money so whether
or not the full sum was returned or not
is unclear but i hope he let least kept
a little [ __ ] the banks
uh bill i swear to god i thought he was
[ __ ] with me until i found multiple
newspaper articles about the robbery
and named him by name confirming all of
this i was blown away is there any way
that you can confirm that he could
actually look at a car key and cut it
from memory
man i don't know anything about
cutting keys but that seems like
i thought he i was just making sure he
wasn't an old man putting a little
mustard on the story there
anyway he was a great dad he was a great
dad to me he turned his life around and
i couldn't have asked for a better role
model growing up that's great i miss him
but remember him fondly as a father and
as a [ __ ] badass when he was young
how many people out there can say their
dad set a state record that's exactly
how you should bring it up and they'll
be thinking you're talking about track
and be like no he robbed the bank for
the most money at that time 400 grand
so why don't you tell me about your
mother's [ __ ] pie all right thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself all right
um i was a dictator if i was a dictator
of australia
i like that these are getting more
specific i want to hear
i want to have some i know people in
china are listening to this thing i want
to hear what you would do
as a dictator in china
how you would handle it what you would
be doing um
if i was a dictator in china i would
demand that i have those unbelievable
dumplings
everywhere i cannot even tell you how
many times i think of those
when you go to china everybody wants to
go see the great wall go have their food
it is [ __ ]
unbelievable
it's like a cloud all right if i was a
dictator of australia
hey billy baldballs
uh first i will get a baseball bat
with a lot of nails in it let me explain
why well most politicians this is such
an australian way of beginning your rule
a baseball bat with a bunch of nails in
it it's not enough that it's a bat it's
got to have nails sticking out of it
which i actually think is dumb when
there's multiple attackers because if
you hit somebody with it it's going to
get stuck in their meat for a minute
the meat of their back and then you're
trying to pull it out of their love
handle
and you're gonna [ __ ] catch a fresh
one uh while most politicians tend to be
self-serving snakes meet angus taylor
i'm already in his name's angus i'm in
member of the current ruling party the
liberals angus used taxpayer money to
buy water entitlements from a company he
set up in the cayman islands for 80
million did he go to jail nope he claims
he doesn't have a financial interest in
the company so all good there it's not
worth noting that he's listed as a
director of the company in question this
treasonous piece of [ __ ] gets the bat
oh i guess not all angus is from
australia are cool
uh but i have to save
plenty of energy
for the chief [ __ ] our prime
minister
a couple years ago
we had some really bad bushfire and huge
parts of australia were on fire rather
than putting measures in place to fight
the fires our prime minister thought it
would be a good time to take his family
on holiday to hawaii
uh you know whenever you book a vacation
something always comes up i don't care
what level you're at it's a society you
know what i mean it's a
i almost got lost in that word there
however by far the worst thing he's done
in my opinion
he's a member of happy clappy church
of a happy clappy church called hillsong
think joel olsteen
think joel osteen i just love that
expression happy clappy church
yay
another florentine shout out and in the
middle of covid lockdown last year when
none of us could even go across state
lines to visit
family our prime minister gave
permission
to the head of hillsong
oh god that's such a creepy name to
leave the company country to set up a
branch in mexico
oh yeah he's lying in his [ __ ]
pockets
and he's not giving him wafers
was brian houston
it says was brian houston head of
hillsong
doing the lord's work oh sorry nope he
was being investigated for covering up
his dad's
kitty fiddling
then our treasonous sack of [ __ ] prime
minister let him out of the country
yeah i mean this is this is how they let
him slide
you know
if your buddy committed a crime and the
cops show up and you know he's hiding
under the table what do you say have you
seen him no i have not
they just do it at up at a higher level
they're us
with power um so if i was a dictator i
would take hgh so i don't get tired from
sweating swinging my bat of justice if
there is a silver line lining brian
houston is about to be charged
uh you crush it as mayfield uh thank you
uh it's actually mayfeld but i'll you
know mayfield all right um really great
stuff thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all
right i appreciate it um
being ugly sucks don't i know it hello
billo
burka
uh just wanted to say thank you for the
podcast been listening for the past two
years and it's one of the little bright
spots in my life
that i cherish well isn't that nice
person goes on to say now
let's get set
um i was recently courting this lady
who i thought at a genu i had a genuine
connection with oh gee what could go
wrong
here's my heart
what do you have to say um we hooked up
on the first date however during the
second date i got cold vibes and could
tell she was not feeling it
well you should have walked
you know de niro and heat you should
have just left
after the date i asked hey i felt like i
should have made a move but was getting
mixed signals
in which she replied it was good you
didn't as i am also seeing someone else
and i don't want to lead you on
oh
i see all right my question is
how does an ugly guy like me ever hope
to find love when all the girls i
thought were a little interest
just end up friend zoning me first of
all she didn't friend zone you you
hooked up with her on the first date
right
um
i have experienced love once and was
generally happy but the relationship
broke down
because her her parents didn't approve
of my ethnicity
a running theme in my life as i am an
asian male
on top of that no one really wants to
set me up with friends as i am not a
real really a looker case in point my
buddy just got out of a relationship
and has been instantly hooked up with
girls who want to see him
well i've been alone for three years now
jesus christ you weren't kidding
now let's get sad you got a sense of
humor though buddy you're still in the
game if you can make them laugh you're
in the game
uh in a society that's hyper focused on
look aesthetic and height how can this
little asian man hope to find a girl who
doesn't just reject me right away sorry
if this sounds a little deranged it
doesn't i feel for you
i feel for you um i've been struggling
with these thoughts for my whole life
now i'm a 21 year old male dude you got
your whole life ahead of you all right
get your head out of the oven hang on a
second any advice would mean a lot and
hopefully shine a little light at the
end of the tunnel all right first of all
you're a man
it doesn't matter what you look like
all right it matters about what's in
your wallet
now right now what i'm going to give you
advice
okay if you want advice on how to find
love don't listen to this but if you
just want a [ __ ] hot woman
all right you need to make money
hot chicks don't give a [ __ ] what you
look like
they know they're hot
but they know they're only hot for a
certain amount of time
so they want to get what the [ __ ] they
can get i'm not saying all hot women i'm
just saying almost all of them all right
so they want a guy that's making [ __ ]
money
all right you start making money but
then the thing about it is dude is then
you got to start i believe the kids say
flossing
is that what they say you got to go out
there and you gotta you gotta uh you
gotta stunt
is that a word is that what the kids say
way back 50 cent
right he said he taught us all how to
stunt didn't he i think that's what he
claimed it anyways
i don't know if he's been like al gore
when he claimed to invent the internet
but i believed him when he said it i was
impressed
it's a hell of a video
you're just gonna i'm giving you advice
on how to attract a [ __ ] all right this
is what you need to do first of all you
need to feel better about yourself
okay if you're walking around like
[ __ ] charlie brown you know with your
head looking down at your [ __ ]
loafers yeah women don't want to bang
that women like excitement
all right if you're not excited about
yourself know what else is gonna be
you ever see somebody selling a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] car they make it sound
like it's a cadillac that's what you got
to do you got to start looking at
yourself like you're a [ __ ] caddy and
not a chevy citation
all right there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
you can do
start going to the gym
you got to use that sense of humor i saw
it like three times in that
all right women love to laugh okay if
you're an easygoing guy you make people
[ __ ] laugh and if you make fun of
yourself
you know what i mean you're gonna you're
gonna be attractive to people
and the more you put yourself out there
and you just [ __ ] you know you gotta
be who you are
all right who gives a [ __ ] there's
nothing wrong with being asian there's
nothing wrong with being short
and you're probably not nearly as bad
looking as you think you are just get
out there put out a [ __ ] positive
vibe all right the great thing about you
know something
the one of the hardest things hot chicks
have is finding love
you know because everybody wants to [ __ ]
them and they'll just lie and say that
they do and they never know who's you
know
it's almost like they're like
celebrities
from what i've heard
[Laughter]
i always see that in the celebrity
interviews yeah it's really hard to
trust people um
anyway what the [ __ ] was i talking
you're gonna be fine
you're 21 years old someday you're going
to be 31 going what the [ __ ] was i
thinking i was 21 i should have been
walking up to women saying hello and
putting it out there what's the worst
thing they can say is no you know what
you got to do you got to stop taking
this rejection so [ __ ] hard
all right everybody gets rejected in
life
okay nobody gets a pass you're not
special
it's it's not
uniquely sad for you
that you got rejected all right welcome
to the [ __ ] human race that's what
happens
all right
i mean i walked around and i looked like
i had a goddamn brush fire on my head
for the most of my [ __ ] life you know
and i somehow plowed through that
you know and i have a lovely wife two
beautiful [ __ ] kids and i'm having a
great time and there's no way you're as
ugly as i am okay so there's your hope
all right
so two things figure out what you want
to do in life go after it and start
[ __ ] talking to the broads there or
whatever the [ __ ] you're into and uh
have a good time and don't be down on
yourself cause if you are you're gonna
be jerking off way more than you're
gonna be [ __ ] and it sounds like
that's not what you want all right now
get out there and make me proud all
right everybody that's the podcast
for uh february 7 2022
that's it i think i'm putting my money
on i know i'm putting my money on the
bengals all right but i'm betting with
my heart all right nothing against the
rams i like the rams too it's a fun
super bowl i like both teams but i just
like the i don't know i've been rooting
for joe burrow since he was at [ __ ]
lsu
um
all right so that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll check in on you on
thursday